avoue gaspard port elle est pas belle la
vie
gaspard
[Applaudissements]
alors oui avant de présenter mes voeux
pour 2013 j'ai une pensée émue pour tous
les syriens qui se sont souhaité une
bonne santé et qu'ils n'ont peut-être
pas eu le temps de finir cette phrase
d'ailleurs je me demande mais cette
année pour la france c'est pas des voeux
qu'il faudrait présenter mais des
prières alors tout le monde dit que 2013
sera plus dur que 2012 ah bon c'est
possible c'est le passé mais non enfin
c'est une bonne année aux pauvres en
2013 qu'ils se rassurent ils vont se
sentir de moins en moins seuls et c'est
toujours moins dure comme ça à la
pauvreté c'est comme la chaude pisse en
garnison temps tu es seul tu as honte
quand ai dit si tu la compare avec
celles des autres
voilà
faut positiver donc 2013 l'année de la
transition des emplois de l'industrie
vers ceux des services à ce camp même
pas rien sortir de la mine pour aller à
la une peut
quitter la lampe frontale pour le néon
de pôle emploi c'est l'anpe c'est qu'une
étape 1 avant le rsa les restos du coeur
emmaüs jean marc morandini
est vraiment au pire il ya la mendicité
mais la mendicité c'est quoi ces c'est
du théâtre de rue avec une mise en scène
minimaliste
c'est vrai qu'il se passe pas grand
chose mais au moins il y a une vraie
transparence sur les subventions
en 2013 façon j'ai décidé de me calmer
je ne vais plus du tout tapé sur
l'exécutif un dupont et dupond c'est
fini je ne perds au holland sais je peux
plus rien alors c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être pas des flèches mais pour une
fois que dans ce pays on a le choix
entre deux noms pour appeler le soldat
inconnu
et dans la foulée j'aimerais présenter
mes voeux aux 75% qui passeront l'hiver
ah oui ça je suis sûr on aura bien les
75 % jusqu'à la fin du quinquennat sauf
que ça va pas concerner le taux
d'imposition mais le chiffre du chômage
alors comme quoi chez les socialistes si
on a l'intuition du chiffre on n'a pas
forcément la certitude de son objet
en tout cas je souhaite une bonne année
au conseil constitutionnel qui est
devenu le centre de planning familial du
ps 1 c c'est là où se font avorter
toutes les lois socialistes
on n'imaginait pas les membres les sages
en avorteurs m'enfin bon c'est comme ça
c'est la vie tout arrive
non je vous passe les détails ce qui
arrivera dans quatre ans à tout le monde
le sait réélection de sarko au premier
tour momification de liliane bettencourt
ouverture de son mausolée place de la
concorde
ce sera évidemment une catastrophe pour
le cinéma français je veux dire même si
depardieu va revenir vu sa grande
moralité torreton va sans doute quitter
la france et prendre un passeport
nord-coréen
[Rires]
et
tout le monde sait ce qui arrive si tard
et on quitte la france enfin n'y a plus
un film qui va se monter
pardon
2013 commence assez bien pour les
salariés de virgin oui ils vont pouvoir
partir au ski avant les autres
parce que chez virgin et oui on solde
aussi les employés n'ont forcément je me
suis précipité quand j'ai déjà repéré
une vendeuse pas mal
c'est mon côté salafistes atequacy et
dans un magasin qui s'appelle virgin et
seront forcément tout de première main
évidemment tout le monde s'indigne que
virgin dépose le bilan fait ça il était
temps que vendre des cd des dvd pourquoi
pas des minitel et des machines à écrire
facile en fait virgin megastore ce
n'était pas un magasin mais un musée des
succès du 20e siècle
on peut de galéjades économique
alors ça fait scandale à sa réveiller
des consciences chez vous c'était c'est
terrible à 24 heures avant la fermeture
la ministre de la culture a émis une
hypothèse c'est peut-être à cause de la
concurrence du commerce en ligne
waouh et on est en 2013 filippetti
découvre amazon
formé h le rythme je veux dire à ce
rythme dans un an et louvre un compte
itunes et dans deux ans elle arrive à
poster une vidéo sur facebook venant
bravo bravo aurait dit
je souhaite également une bonne année
2013 à la première manif de l'année
enfin la première manif de laisser le le
machin contre mariage pour tous ou pour
suis plus très bien ce espèce de cgt de
la sexualité normative là qui va battre
le pavé le grand défilé pour la
pénétration des orifices socialement
acceptable
au
moins dans ce pays on a le sens des
priorités je me demande si ça va être
quoi les slogans puisqu'on vous dit que
c'est pas le bon trop
l'anus c'est que pour le bonus
voire des cathos défilé contre le
mariage c'est à peu près aussi crédible
que de voir des végétariens militer pour
l'abattage halal causé
tout cas la sexualité gay aura au moins
un mérite faire parler les cathos de la
leur ce qui leur arrive assez rarement
en temps en même temps un truc je vois
pas très bien pourquoi ils s'excitent au
sujet de la pma est fait pour fallait
pas retirer cette loi c'est très bien la
pm ainsi en plus qu'est-ce que c'est
d'ailleurs la procréation médicalement
assistée c'est quoi c'est faire l'amour
avec en se faisant tenir le sexe par
michel cymes c'est ça le
moi je comprends pas d'ailleurs pourquoi
l'église et contre la procréation
médicalement assistée de la pma c'est
quoi c'est la procréation sur le péché
de l'acte en fait c'est l'église devrait
être pourquoi c'est une sorte de
d'éjaculer conception costumes
2013 je souhaite également que la presse
française sont un peu plus objective si
elle pouvait enfin reconnaître que
vladimir poutine est un démocrate doublé
d'un humaniste alors mais vous
connaissez beaucoup de présidents qui
naturalise d'un étranger en trois jours
2013 le printemps arabe qui a donné sa
première récolte un pas très
convaincante c'est un seul bizarre quoi
c'est un insolent tu plantes de la
démocratie pouce de la charia
ferait peut-être mieux de plantes et de
la dictature aurait plus de chances de
retrouver de la démocratie quoi rien
ce qui m'amène au sujet des décapitation
en arabie saoudite une transition
naturelle
76 décapitation en 2012 en arabie
saoudite on s'y prend mal pour exporter
la démocratie fin dans ces pays là
peut-être que si on leur fournissait la
guillotine il ferait le lien avec la
déclaration des droits de l'homme je
sais pas
c'est plus intelligent profond mais
faut terminer par une bonne nouvelle
peut être jack lang qui a enfin trouvé
un point de chute l'institut du monde
arabe
ça prouve donc que les rumeurs sur le
poste de garde champêtre place des
vosges était fausse
mais ce qu'on vous dit que c'est les
soldes alors babel l'année et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube
abonnez vous je m'étais 1 pouces bleus